economía aquí en directo América edición
nocturna me acompaña en el estudio Jorge
Hurtado Jorge muy buenas noches
comenzamos en nuestra región en
Argentina porque presentaron los datos
de inflación que casi llegó al 100%
anual todo esto para el 2022 qué más
dijeron Santiago la inflación anual ahí
fue en diciembre del 94,8% la más alta
desde 1991 y casi el doble de lo
registrado en 2021 que fue del
50,9%, los analistas independientes
prevén una inflación del 98% para este
año Aunque el gobierno afirma que bajará
al 60% anual el índice de precio es el
consumidor de Argentina visto en
términos intermensuales subió 5,1% en
diciembre según los datos del Instituto
Nacional de estadísticas y censos de
Argentina la inflación actualmente es
una de las principales preocupaciones de
los argentinos porque afecta el poder
adquisitivo y también repercute en ya su
devaluada moneda local escuchemos
a medida digamos de que uno al
supermercado de barrio todos los días a
dando cuenta que ya es intolerable tener
que ir a buscar precio entonces bueno en
la medida de las posibilidades que uno
tiene puede venir acá al mercado central
pero también es desgastante no es un
factor psicológico que te desgasta
porque es ir a buscar precio pensar que
en un lado puede estar más caro más
barato y uno la verdad que necesita de
alguna forma ajustarse con los precios
porque bueno el salario también no
aumenta como aumenta la inflación y
bueno la plata no alcanza Los sueldos
tampoco la inflación sigue subiendo Y
bueno ya empezamos el año ya con aumento
ya de colectivo de paquete de lo que es
ropa alimento entonces bueno Tratamos de
hacer lo que podemos yo vengo con el
changuito Vengo al colectivo
tengo que llevar las cosas viste cargada
en el colectivo y para ganarle un poco a
la inflación y al sueldo viste que
alcance y venir acá al central y
recorrer también Ver precio es una
Argentina pero Tal parece que en Estados
Unidos la inflación sí está dando un
respiro a los consumidores en ese país
Así es ahí descendió al 6,5% anual en
diciembre en comparación con el año
anterior según informó el gobierno se
trata del sexto descenso interanual
consecutivo en los precios en términos
mensuales los precios bajaron solamente
un 0,1% de noviembre a diciembre y es la
primera caída desde mayo del 2020 Es
probable que esta caída de los precios
del gas siga reduciendo la inflación
general en los próximos meses también
los problemas de la cadena de suministro
ya se van resolviendo y está ayudando a
reducir el costo de bienes que van desde
los vehículos y los zapatos hasta los
muebles y los artículos deportivos en
ese país Jorge hablemos ahora de el
gobierno del presidente de Brasil Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva que presentó una
ambición soplan todo esto para intentar
reducir el déficit fiscal en ese país de
qué se trata el anuncio lo hizo el
ministro de hacienda de Brasil Fernando
ajad quien presentó este un primer
conjunto de medidas que adoptará el
gobierno alguna de ellas impopulares
como el aumento de impuestos a grandes
empresas y a los combustibles también se
contempla el fraccionamiento de deudas
Fiscales y la reducción de gastos
públicos el déficit fiscal del
presupuesto de este año está previsto en
el dos coma uno por ciento del producto
interno bruto brasileño o sea unos 46
mil millones de dólares en caso de que
estas medidas resulten efectivas Brasil
podría cerrar el 2023 con un superávit
primario de
11.130 millones de reales o unos 2.226
millones de dólares según los cálculos
de ese ministerio el Ministerio de
economía brasileño admitió que las
medidas van a ser graduales para
equilibrar el presupuesto de este año y
que se pueden tener inclusive algunas
frustraciones que obligaría a adoptar
otras normas ya veremos Entonces si la
fórmula les funciona allí en Brasil
según un estudio del foro económico
mundial más médicos y más docentes van a
ser necesitados en el mundo en los años
que el planeta necesita incrementar un
37% el número de trabajadores de estos
sectores hasta llegar a los 64 millones
en 2030 el foro económico mundial sitúa
a Brasil y a España como el segundo y el
tercer país con un mayor déficit de
empleados en el ámbito social que
incluyen a los sectores de la salud el
cuidado de los niños y de la educación
Pero el líder En esa lista es Sudáfrica
según el análisis faltan 18 millones de
sanitarios 12 millones de cuidadores y
profesores infantiles y 9 millones de
docentes de Educación primaria y
secundaria en el mundo solamente en
Brasil Santiago hay 10,2 millones de
personas trabajando en sectores de la
economía social una cifra que el foro
cree que debería incrementarse un 89%
antes del año 2030 también advierten
sobre la necesidad de aumentar en un 66%
el número de empleados en la economía
verde que incluye los sectores agrícolas
pesqueros y la construcción
y para el cierre la cifra del día
sorpréndanos esta Te va a encantar 22
twingos son necesarios para comprar un
Ferrari esto a propósito de la última
canción de Shakira que creó tendencia al
referirse a estas dos grandes marcas de
vehículos el cálculo lo hace bloomber en
línea que claramente compara el precio
de los modelos más económicos del twingo
de Renault que ronda los 10.700 dólares
y el de un Ferrari económico que ronda
los 232 mil dólares ese twingo tiene
alma de Ferrari siempre lo he dicho tuve
uno cuando era adolescente Muchas
gracias Jorge por este reporte a
continuación en directo a América el
debate